now to an update on a powerful story of
transformation and Second Chances we
first told you about Missouri Prison
inmate Bobby Bostic back in 2019. he was
serving a 241 year sentence for series
of robberies he committed when he was
only 16 years old Bostic is now 43 and
he has changed his life in prison he
went to school he read and wrote books
even though he had no hope of ever
getting out but that has all changed
thanks to an unlikely Ally 48 Hours
correspondent Aaron Moriarty has been
covering bostic's case for years
43 year old Bobby bossick was making
more than a fashion statement when he
walked away from a Missouri prison last
week in a brand new suit the new me the
suits represent the new me and it's a
business suit and often to go on with
the new business of life so that's what
the Super Brothers think boss six first
hug Evelyn Baker God I'm so happy happy
too the now retired judge who sent
Bostic to prison but spent the last four
years fighting to get him out you were
emotional when he walked out towards you
yep
he made me cry all right wasn't trying
to this day one seemed inconceivable
Bostic was incarcerated in 1995 at age
16 after he and a friend committed a
series of armed robberies in St Louis
one victim was grazed by a bullet did
you intend to hurt him to kill him no I
attend to her to kill him I'd have kept
shooting convince bossick was a lost
cause Judge Baker showed no mercy after
he was convicted on 17 counts the judge
ordered his sentences to run
consecutively for a total of 241 years
we visited basic in prison again two
weeks before his release were you angry
with her no it motivated me to say one
day if I ever do get out I would see her
and she would realize the mistakes she
made when she see the person I became
that didn't seem very likely bossick
wouldn't be eligible for parole until he
was 112 years old many people would have
just given up but basic found Drive even
when he had nowhere to go once you make
so many mistakes you get tired you want
to do something different so I started
reading that's how I found myself in
books and that's the most piece I ever
get in the world it's a natural high
basically basic obtained an associate's
degree and is working now on his
bachelor's in business he wrote poetry
and prose 15 books in all including a
biography of his mother His stunning
turnaround convinced Judge Baker she
made a mistake 241 years is insanity
when I think back on it and I'll say
right now it's insanity he was a kid he
was a little boy but you're the one who
sentenced him judge yes as he evolved I
have evolved I mean is it fair to say
that the case of Bobby vasik has haunted
you
that would be a very true statement
Judge Baker began advocating for Bostic
in the summer of 2021 the Missouri
legislature passed the Bobby bossick Law
which allowed him and other inmates
incarcerated his juveniles to apply for
parole how unusual is that for the trial
judge who sentenced an inmate to then
appear at the parole hearing asking for
his release I don't know if it ever
happened before
but it was something I wanted to do why
because it was time for Bobby to come
home and be with his family
he wasn't a kid I sent and late last
year the parole board gave basic a date
when he could finally go home and then
when I see my name on the paper this
morning and said released Bobby bossy
released I'm like it's official
so you do have a very strange unique
Bond
yes you put him in prison and you helped
him get out the Bobby Bostic I put in
prison it's not the Bobby Bostic who got
out
Bobby
what many people can't do
he created himself
he took The Good The Bad and The Ugly
and he turned into something that's
quite beautiful
you feel good about today
I'm ecstatic
this is better than Christmas Easter
Fourth of July Thanksgiving rolling in
one
my God his family thought so too
there'll be some people who won't think
you and other men who've been convicted
as juveniles deserve a second chance
what do you say to them oh well some
people
um they got a right to feel that way
basically right it's up to us the
juveniles will get out and get the
second chance to do something different
to prove to those people like I'm just
like you
well clearly basic has a lot to be
thankful for this year and if you're
wondering where he'll be spending his
first Thanksgiving as a free man Judge
Baker invited him and his family over
for dinner tonight while in prison
Busick started a non-profit called Dear
Mama that's what you're looking at here
that aims to help single mothers in need
earlier this week they held a food drive
and a clothing Drive Bostic bought all
the food himself since his release he
also performed his poetry at an open mic
passed his driver's license test and
worked his sister says he's doing well
at her cleaning company I really get the
sense that um Bobby bossick is trying to
make up for all this lost time but why
this is a perfect Thanksgiving story is
because we take so much for granted and
when you lose so much like he did like
just being able to go to bed when you
decide take a shower when you decide and
he's just so when I talk to him he's
just brimming over with excitement and
he go ahead said reading brings him
peace and it really does seem as if he
was able to change himself while serving
time and that was the change maker he
said a weird thing you know you could
get marijuana in prison you shouldn't be
able to but he did he said it stopped
working for him he couldn't escape and
books gave him what drugs didn't I was
very taken aback by that that he could
Escape in books what you do I am
thankful for that you're getting a great
story great story you've been following
his story all along and so many people
who you know needed a second chance
right and you've given it to them well
these are great stories they're great
people honestly like all right Aaron
thanks thanks to you thank you